what is happening reject nation my name
is Greg the Elba
I'll take lightly Howard hit here I
never I was going to let you say your
name but then I'm like you know I've
said your name for all them I should
probably say yeah I know I'm not good
actor ah god absolute Howard 2012 on
Instagram and Twitter
just what are not Instagram you said it
wrong every video and Twitter it'll say
well what's yours on Instagram
Stacy Oh Howard oh damn it it's alright
though just like my Twitter and then all
my stuff is on Twitter so it's okay
we're going to let's start again let's
cut the video can be cut no I just do
jump cousin I keep all this crashing
sorry about spider-man homecoming
trailers through from this channel
called toon sandwich
they've been compared to the likes of
how it should have ended well they're
different though like they're finding
content they it's like because they're
animated spoofs that's why they get
compared but their Seuss style is
different and there the more is how
should have been is very much about like
how it should've ended I know a few
scenes of how the movie could have ended
fast you're right this is just a little
bit different I'm assuming you've seen
this trailer for a movie called
spider-man homecoming I am aware and
familiar I'm familiar do this DC
characters I don't care who is this
spider-man
anyway let's watch it alright do it like
so on
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers what the hell I want
you to stay home tonight
ah why are you guys Bobby yeah yeah then
just doesn't pay as well as we allegedly
you kid I've got gambling debts well
this is super awkward for me because I
gotta arrest you guys we should know the
vault I realize that now no but I do
this okay let's go
just wear slippers should probably stop
staring for this creepy Oh too late you
guys are losers isn't that right mr.
mobile screen loser so to become an
Avenger are there like trials there's a
Tron what a faking have to do with being
an adventurer we already have people to
fight crime what we don't have is a
decent friggin pastry chef eater you
still with us really chattering I was
just watching Captain America Civil War
on my left you can't watch a movie that
sent me over to choose yourself occupied
that's called a trail of Hanuman I
didn't what yeah so you just damaged 500
bucks were delayed oh you're the
spider-man no not sure about it was I or
was it you who was on the ceiling and
happy in your whole life
sure just blew my boy 19600 step one of
my fitness challenge inject yourself
with a special super soldier sir that's
pretty much it
do you know him - Peter Parker if you're
watching this connect these on my shirt
back he's obviously referring to a
different Peter Parker Peter Parker from
Queens aka the spider-man hey who threw
that
are you better this I don't think so
rich to the powerful like starting they
don't care about us patience dr.
foundation just arrived
probably the others should get the
flying monster going there are people
who handle this sort of thing fly
monster gangbusters for example if you
made you quit slack widow which you eat
you afterwards it'd be worth it almost
may I see your ticket things are about
to get very unstable I'm a little busier
than one oh I see you're not my fan see
you soon magazine oh don't worry ma'am
I'll save you unbelievable a woman that
was almost drenched I'm going to need a
suit back but I'm nothing without this
suit is there nothing about this suit
you shouldn't have it of all people do
he can do like a cool room stark-naked
[Music]
Batman I mean burg I mean Bulger sorry
played a lot of wing it characters
sometimes I get ruffled
yeah Polly want a cracker don't push me
kid
well yes we said know it remember in a
famine an exact hey where you going
come back these aren't so bad okay now
they're bad oh don't do anything in here
that's my playground I know I say the
second trick this is the last time I fly
honey
sorry sir all we have left is some fish
well what a surprise
okay Pierre you can do this source it's
all about conference hello hi hi hey is
that Natasha who is it it's me
a few spotty creepy minutes butter heart
a beer Parker I never chose any of those
things
what about one air crash here and like
the airport you want to join me
mr. starch friends in Queens you know
spider-man the big as an M Oh God all
right the web guy yeah sure things in
distress but yeah how did you get my
number
mr. stark gave it to me I'll have to
remember to thank him for that
so how can I help you st. John Pete up
here well look here's the situation I've
got my school's homecoming dance coming
up in a few weeks and I was kind of
wondering if you would you know want to
go with come with me to it you want me
to be your date well let me think about
it we have so much in common
most superheroes those with the record
based code names both fought for
teamironman
I know you're ultimately betray us today
what happens in life big stage unlikely
plus subpoenas fancy dress so we could
wear a actual superhero suit and no no I
can't want a nice suit to a dance that
thing does not breathe every time I peel
it off as our hard day's avenging my
whole body's ghosting of sweat yeah
Oh God boss that oh oh nothing I just uh
accidentally press the trigger and I
wish shooters actually
also Pierre I'm not sure if you're aware
of this but I kind of have a boyfriend
it's a long distance relationships at
the moment but I wanted to stay
explosive well we even have to find out
I mean from what mrs. dog tells me he's
somewhat unreachable trust me you don't
wanna risk his suffers from what
sometimes described as a short temper
well can I at least bring along a photo
of you until people were going out left
patron I'm gonna have to call you back
I just got out of shower and I'm also
being trippin you spider him he's by
your tail you spider he came that's
what's going on Stacy doesn't pick up on
sexual jokes
I don't know I'm Elena yeah he was
coming oh well where was he going
you coming comedy but uh Rob UCB so do
some growling flowers hilarious they're
funny guys huh funny
yeah they're animation style is amazing
and the Michael Keaton impression fun oh
the impressions were there I mean the
voices especially like I said of
Scarlett Johansson voices if I felt like
I was in her I thought I was Joaquin
Phoenix like you were huh yeah believe
all these awkward pauses in yeah they
just took it there with someone from the
physical comment which is great he's
like a half an egg what's great and
little baby vultures baby bolt there's
the whole time yeah my favorite moment I
think was when Michelle started calling
the losers and saucy and do the cup that
was probably my bag as laughs a lot
I'm a mr. buzzby mixer Mugsy but spit
ours are here again you should probably
stop staring before this creepy though
too late
you guys are losers isn't that right
uncle noble scheme not I don't like that
so fun hey cab I don't know if I went
inside on a video release but the guy
Ned he's Filipino I'm half Filipino
meaning my Filipinos are part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now nice yeah
representation without taxation yeah
that was it that's exactly I know I know
what's happening I'm so happy that the
first Filipino character is ned nice not
a superhero not a superhero I bought my
god oh my god yeah chubby guy I could
have played him I cut up yeah definitely
I played this monday chubby guy and you
can told I think in real life you're
kind of a funny chubby guy with the
personality you have oh you don't look
like a funny chubby guy that's the look
I'm going for the raising I'm not chubby
enough oh you're definitely obese look I
can't do anything right I mean the
camera loses 10 pounds that's everyone
does actually [ __ ] everyone knows that's
what she's really yeah she takes up a
lot of space she's comple sweating yeah
all these jump cuts in the video are to
deal with her perspiration prompts we
got a spray bottle here to cool her
house that's also for you see missing a
vicious rape a very common thing spider
comes spider telling your head spider
come on my face you get spider come on
my face all day Stacy whoa you think
it's those spider-man uses fingers yes
well that's probably dip into this whole
even better one you know what I mean
though yeah like when you oh yeah well I
don't know yeah brides be uncomfortable
for Bolton it yeah yeah man it much
really easy to get that when it's
spider-man yeah yeah this is Hancock
anyway
visitor things I
think about what happened much of a
minor man room video this happens you
just gotta go for it he's gotta go work
I think it'd be great if spider-man and
Natasha start a relationship in some way
kind of romantic chemistry I definitely
see some kind of relationship though
like a kind of an elderly sister to
younger brother kid brother okay see
that yeah for sure I could see him
really having to I could see him being
like the young guy who's like the high
school or as a crush oh yeah hole or
girl yeah you know I guess you should do
Black Widow yes no doubt oh I don't know
there are so many characters that I want
to do but Black Widow will be the
easiest you pull it off the red hair
it's a possibility you you're you're
thin enough I don't know if I pop test
this yeah yeah thank you my glutes your
glute my squat in my glutes your glutes
I've never checked out your ass never
never whenever she walks in front of me
I've never once looked down yep I've
never checked out my ass either it's
hard to see it now that's why this girl
anytime I like to hung out with her
she's constantly trying to look at her
ass and having other people look at her
ass yeah I'm not like I'm like Stacy I'm
a good-hearted Mormon I will not look at
your ass your nose for Mary's well we
have to get married I always knew I get
proposed to this way thank you I'm going
to talk about it fertilizer yeah we all
have a little net enough that way yes
anyway this is the group discussion you
had I thought the game of thrones was aa
weird hop our song and go further and
further
chomping over there just watch - let us
not make any but let's go upward and
bring it around a sexual material behind
stories that's the formula we have now
they subscribe to tune sandwich when you
get the chance Thursday's are worth it
they're actually not called tuna
sandwich they're called art Speer
entertainment and they have 251 that Wow
when I first saw their video they are
growing through the ad hoc it's good for
you guys and also subscribe to us if you
want you can but more importantly
subscribe to hit or miss movies and
follow Stacy on social media Twitter so
Howard 2012 yeah Instagram that you see
a word yapping yeah that's it you stop
yeah